à quel moment dans votre vie vous vous
êtes déjà demandé quand est-ce que vous
avez cassé les codes c'est vrai que
c'est une question que je me suis posée
en essayant de vouloir un petit peu
regarder en quoi consistait ce sujet et
c'est là que je me suis dit en fait la
première fois que j'ai cassé les codes
c'est pas du tout en lançant mon
entreprise alors que j'étais au lycée
mais c'est plutôt quand j'ai réalisé que
j'étais déjà une adulte alors que
officiellement d'après les codes de la
société je n'avais pas encore 18 ans
parce qu'à l'époque j'étais plus proche
de mes professeurs que de mes camarades
de classe je m'habillais entre
guillemets comme une adulte jamais vous
auriez pu me voir en basket ou en pull à
capuche donc c'est vrai que je copie
beaucoup les codes des adultes et même
dans ma manière de parler on prenait
souvent un petit peu trop au sérieux
parce que bah forcément j'étais pas très
jeune dans le langage de nos parents et
c'est là où je me suis dit en fait j'ai
déjà cassé ces codes là mais pourquoi
les gens de ma génération ne l'ont pas
encore fait peut-être que je suis trop
en avance ou peut-être eux trop en
retard c'est vrai que je suis une grande
passionnée de politique et donc c'est là
où je me suis dit il faut lancer un
média qui parle aux jeunes pour les
jeunes et par des jeunes et pour que je
puisse tout simplement avoir des
discussions sympas avec des gens de mon
âge et donc en fait l'histoire s'est
enchaîné comme ça j'ai lancé mon média
et avec heureusement j'ai eu la chance
de pouvoir le faire avec mon frère donc
ce qui était plutôt sympa comme
environnement et en fait j'ai réalisé
que ceux qui s'intéressaient à la
politique c'est pas forcément ceux enfin
même si j'avais beau créer avoir créé
mon média ce à la fin qui regardait les
vidéos c'était des gens en fait qui
aimaient déjà ça de base pas forcément
ceux en qui tu pouvais typiquement je
peux te dire tiens va regarder un débat
de politique je suis sûr que tu vas
aimer si de base tu n'aimes pas
forcément ça en fait bah tu vas pas
forcément aimer ça à la fin parce qu'en
fait c'est vrai qu'on est une génération
où on est plutôt assez flemmard moi même
d'ailleurs je le reconnais mais qu'en
fait dès qu'on le donne les clés en main
de quelque chose ils vont on est quand
même assez curieux je trouve et donc si
on arrive à nous donner un tout petit
peu cet aspect curiosité à nous lui
donner vraiment en main parce que s'il y
a trop de clics il y a trop de choses à
faire on le fait jamais à la fin on
arrive quand même à s'intéresser à
différents sujets et c'est vrai que
casser les codes moi je le lis
énormément à l'entrepreneuriat parce que
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui moi à
l'époque enfin quand on me disait de
l'entrepreneuriat je voyais énormément
ça comme un jeune homme de 25-30 ans
habillé en chemise avec une veste jean
et des baskets et forcément un monde
très très masculin et en fait j'ai
réalisé en rentrant dans ce monde-là que
il y a énormément de femmes en fait dans
l'entrepreneuriat mais d'un point de vue
extérieur on s'en rend pas compte
peut-être parce que après les femmes
peuvent élever leurs enfants comme elles
arrivent à gérer l'emploi du temps elles
arrivent à faire les deux en même temps
ce qui est plutôt assez pratique mais en
fait l'entrepreneuriat pour moi c'est
d'abord une question de mentalité plus
une question de faire quelque chose ou
d'avoir une idée l'entrepreneuriat c'est
pas quand tu te dis tiens je vais
innover je vais lancer un projet qui va
révolutionner le monde ou qui va changer
ma propre vie ou celle de mes camarades
l'entrepreneuriat c'est d'abord une
plutôt un fait de personnalité de
comment tu penses comment tu vois les
choses et c'est pour ça que
l'entrepreneuriat donc l'innovation donc
pour moi cassé les codes que je lis
énormément ensemble mais c'est pas
vraiment cassé les codes c'est plus
transformer innover créent ensemble
quelque chose
après c'est vrai que on a un système
éducatif aujourd'hui qui nous pousse pas
du tout à changer les codes on nous
apprend toujours à faire Bachelor
licence master ou pas ce que vous voulez
parce que si on fait pas ça on a
forcément raté notre vie et je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec ça donc pour moi
par contre là oui il faut casser les
codes de notre système éducatif qu'on a
actuellement parce que de plus en plus
ça se fait dans certaines écoles moi
j'ai fait une licence à côté de mon
média qui était assez moderne parce
qu'on faisait beaucoup plus de pratique
que théoriques je me suis dit ah bah
enfin pas des cours théoriques que
j'oublierai trois mois après et qu'en
fait quand j'arriverai dans le monde du
travail ça va me servir à pas grand
chose mais en fait même cette école là
qui se disait très moderne qui se disait
elle-même avoir déjà cassé les codes
quand je leur disais que j'avais à côté
de ça j'ai également fondé mon
entreprise on me le reprochait en mode
tu dois d'abord faire tes études pour
après fonder ton entreprise et j'étais
un peu en mode ok alors vous êtes une
école moderne vous voulez casser des
codes vous dites que vous cassez des
codes et ces zen d'ailleurs le slogan
entre guillemets limite qu'il mette en
avant mais en fait quand on le fait ça
vous embête un peu parce que c'est là où
en fait ils ont pas cassé les cotes
c'est psychologiquement c'est une étape
qui est pas encore passé peut-être parce
que c'est pas la même génération je sais
pas moi je pense oui mais c'est là où je
me suis dit c'est tellement dommage en
fait parce qu'aujourd'hui on est quand
même une génération où on casse les
codes tous les jours sans se rendre
compte je pense que vous avez déjà tous
cassé les codes on est une génération
avec les réseaux sociaux on casse les
codes typiquement aujourd'hui tu peux
apprendre à tes parents en qu'importe le
job qui fait ça peut être la personne la
plus brillante et intelligente du monde
faire trois clics pour poster un truc ça
il est incapable de le faire tu lui
montres une fois tu lui remonte une
deuxième fois il comprend toujours pas
alors franchement c'est hyper simple
parce qu'ils ont pas grandi avec c'est
pas des codes qui ont de leur génération
et c'est là je me suis dit c'est quand
même dingue parce que les gens
aujourd'hui veulent être un peu jeune
c'est un peu devenu la mode de nos
parents ou des générations un peu
anciennes mais
j'y arrive vraiment pas c'est à dire
qu'ils le disent qu'ils le font ils sont
un peu en mode ouais à fond les jeunes
mais en fait psychologiquement c'est une
étape qu'ils n'arrivent pas à comprendre
donc c'est vrai que nous avec les
réseaux sociaux le web 3 qui arrive le
métaverse tout ça etc générations
futures en fait quels sont les codes
sans même se rendre compte vous-même
vous cassez tous les codes dans vos vies
privées dans vos vies professionnels
mais pour moi c'est dangereux de casser
les codes parce que si tu casses les
codes après tu en as de nouveaux qui se
créent donc en fait ça devient un cercle
vicieux parce que tu dois toujours
vouloir encaisser toujours en voulant en
recréer là typiquement ce soir je
pourrais carrément casser des codes d'un
TEDx sans fous faisant tous venir sur
scène là quand je vois vos têtes vous
avez l'air un peu de trouver ça bizarre
parce que forcément c'est pas les codes
d'un TEDx de tous vous faire venir sur
scène je vais pas le faire parce que mon
objectif n'est pas de casser cette
magnifique conférence mais c'est plutôt
de vous faire réaliser que casser les
codes où il y a des domaines il faut le
faire parce qu'il faut carrément recréer
des choses ça c'est sûr mais d'un autre
côté moi je suis plus en mode changer
les choses les améliorer les Adou
parce que c'est vraiment en faisant ça
ensemble que on arrive à vraiment à
changer les choses parce que sinon ça
devient le chaos en fait si on casse les
codes il y a plus vraiment de société il
y a plus vraiment de règles donc en fait
tout par un petit peu en vrille et pour
moi c'est pas forcément bon signe c'est
même très dangereux de faire ça donc
c'est pour ça que je vous dirais plus ce
soir faudrait quand même qu'on décide de
changer les choses ensemble pas de
casser des codes mais de les changer les
améliorer parce que moi je pense que
dans ce beau monde on est en fait tous
ensemble merci
[Applaudissements]